you have to be good at your craft my job
was to perfect my craft being great at
your craft is a requirement
what's that believe nation it's having
my one word is believe it I believe in
you I believe you have Michael Jordan
level talent adds something and I want
you to find it embrace it and use it to
make a difference now I started the one
rule series because I watch a lot of top
tens in making these videos for you and
some of the rules come up over and over
and over and over again so that's the
goal with this series to smush together
the rules that keep coming up
consistently so today we're gonna learn
how to perfect your craft enjoy and the
number one lesson I could offer you
where your work is concerned is this
becomes so skilled so vigilant so
flat-out fantastic at what you do that
your talent cannot be dismissed stop
comparing yourself to other people
[Applause]
you're only on this planet to be you not
someone else's imitation of you I had to
learn that the hard way on the air live
anchoring the news one night in my 20s
when I first started broadcasting I was
19
moved to an anchor by the time I was 20
and I was just pretending to be Barbara
Walker Walters I was just trying to talk
like Barbara acting like Bravo Barbara
hold my legs like Barbara and I was on
the air and I hadn't read the copy fully
and I called Canada Canada and I did
that on the air I crack myself up
because I thought Barbara would never
call Canada Canada and that little break
through that little crack that little
moment that I stopped pretending allowed
the real me to come through your life
journey is about learning to become more
of who you are and fulfilling the
highest truest expression of yourself as
a human being that's why you're here
Fite expect expect to be uncomfortable
and if you're not devoting between 8 and
12 hours a day on your craft then you're
not really trying to be a professional
like you got to realize you trying to be
competitive being a professional means
being the best in the world that doesn't
just come with skill that comes with
discipline you know that means you have
to have a certain kind of work ethic
that means you're doing things that most
won't people really don't understand it
like they think they got skill so
everything is going to come to them
skill is actually like a curse I've seen
people with no skill that realize that
and understand that they had to work
hard to get this skill worked so hard
that they do better than the people that
have skill and that are arrogant and
entitled that feel that it's just come
to them and then they just become a
waste you know having potential is
[ __ ] if you don't realize it it
becomes corny like you're the cool guy
when you have potential but like ten
years later if you don't realize it they
need a corny guy you
and I never want to ever be that guy the
problem is if you have the greatest
hammer and the greatest screwdriver and
the greatest wrench the greatest in
front of you
if you don't use them properly you will
lose right if there's a nail that I have
to put in that ground but I take the
wrench and I hit it when the hammer was
right there it still comes down to the
practitioner mm-hmm and you have to be
good at your craft and you have to love
your if you love sales if you don't love
it you have no chance because it's so
hard it's so painful there's so much
rejection right so those are the things
I think about
so technology's clearly enablers you
just said there that the person is
equally important and more important
right and I just apologize for jumping
in but let me make it perfectly straight
if I go play Roger Federer right now in
tennis and I have the greatest tennis
racquet ever made
like from taken from the Mars is new
like resources right and he took a John
McEnroe 1974 tennis racquet he would
whip my ass like I'm crushing sales
people that have every sales force every
one of your competitors 37 features
upgraded went to every pro conference
watching this I will beat their ass in
sales every day of the week right your
talent you got your ring what's next see
you getting better at what playing
basketball I mean my job was to perfect
my craft and championship or not I got
to perfect my craft and so I can't play
no more and then that's when I'll sit
down at the table and reflect on my
career people put too much faith in the
tools it's not about the tools it's not
about the tools that you're using it's
not about the suit that you're wearing
something about the car that you're
driving it's about you at the end of the
day it comes down to you I was asked to
do a roundup of different entrepreneurs
of what your favorite tool was to help
you build your business and they asked
me and they asked 30 other people what
is the tool that you love most that
helps drive your business forward and I
was the only one who didn't want to give
a tool everybody listed their tools and
I was at the end of the day I was posted
at the very bottom the tools don't
matter stop blaming the tools and
rules are important don't get me wrong I
love using tools I think YouTube is a
great tool I think cameras are a great
tool I use tools every single day in my
business to help spread my message and
help my company grow but it's not the
reliance on the tools this is where I
think a lot of people fall down
I had an entrepreneur friend of mine
come to me says what tools do you use
for your calendar how do you keep track
of your to dues because she had tried
using a notebook and using Evernote and
using OneNote and using all sorts of
different tools using her phone
everything and nothing was working you
know what the problem is not the tools
the problem is you write the tools can
help you go faster but if you don't have
the mindset if you don't have the
ambition if you don't have the drive if
you're not putting in the work then the
tools will never save you and I think
people have an over reliance on the
tools and that's my biggest problem with
it the tools can help you do that last
20% but it's 80% you it's 80% the hustle
in the hard work to get really good at
the thing and the tool can help you go
further I see tools is like pouring
gasoline on a fire you need to have a
spark you need to have a fire to get
something going and then the tool the
gasoline can help it explode but if you
just pour gasoline on wood nothing's
gonna happen I think the same thing
about suits and cars I think a lot of
people think you wear suit now you're
going to be successful suit doesn't mean
anything clothing is an expression of
self not a place where you get your
self-worth somebody with no suit on
could go in and close a sale because
they are who they are they are confident
they can close that sale where somebody
who's only deriving confidence from
their suit will never win and so yes
tools are important but stop relying on
the tools get so darn good at the thing
that you're doing that you cannot be
ignored and then use the tools to help
you take it to the next level when I
started starting everyone says all
you're gonna be a gym teacher I said no
I saw my work with professional athletes
I knew what I wanted to do is I'm gonna
work with but I'm going to work with
professional athletes so that was my
that was the goal I set in my mind and I
just said hey that that's gonna take a
place in my head that's the only thing
that I want to do and I gotta figure out
a way to I got to figure out a way to
get there so I started and learned my
better than anybody else did I start
with the professional athletes Noah
after I graduated I went to work in a
local health club really I knew how I
knew everything from a book standpoint
but still you got to know how to apply
it okay so I you know worked with
anybody I could any these are not pro
these aren't pros I'm talking about
housewives I'm talking about individuals
that just want to get in just want to
get in shape people that have had
injuries from different sports kids
anybody just kind of developing programs
putting implementing what I've learned
and actually being able to apply it and
once I start to look at that craft I
said okay now I'm starting to figure out
how to how to actually apply this stuff
and how to use it and put the formulas
together and put the workouts together
and do all these different things I mean
stuff that they're doing now from a
workout standpoint I was doing 30 years
ago I was new to you know I mean some of
the stuff is you are it's different I
stay on top of it right I got to
continue to learn you know continue to
be better myself so I can better my
athletes better my craft but it it's a
different it's just a different way of
doing the same a different way of doing
the same thing well right now there's a
lot more resources a lot more education
a lot more testing available back then
you kind of had to just figure it out a
lot of individuals now okay
especially in this generation not only
from a training standpoint but from a
knowledge standpoint they're jumping
from one thing to another you know
they're using this trainer this week
they're using another trainer next week
you know they're using this person as a
mentor on YouTube then they're using
this person over here okay and they're
getting all this conflicting information
okay you got a you got a master what
you're going to master okay you have to
fit you have to figure out too many
people are jumping from place to place
the place Michael
Kobe all these individuals they mastered
one aspect of the game when they
mastered that aspect of the game then
they moved to another aspect of the game
being great at your craft is a
requirement yeah yeah and I'm not I
wouldn't suggest that you stop that you
don't try and get work or hustle or do
all those other things while you're
coming up because that's a part of the
game and that's you know Gary Vee is a
big advocate for hustling and so you got
to hustle your whole way but being
greater your craft actually matters yeah
yeah and and having like the camera is
like an extension of my arm and you
think about it I have used the pro golf
analogy I know I'm not crazy about golf
but those guys have to again women have
to stand up on the tee and hit the ball
down the middle because that's what
they're paid to do doesn't matter if
it's raining sunny windy if there's ten
people watching or ten million they're
paid to at the ball in the middle and as
an artist you're paid to make and as an
entrepreneur you're paid to deliver the
the ROI to the shareholders and as a
wrestler you're paid to win or like
whatever your thing is you have to be
great at your craft in order to I think
achieve so there's this 10,000 hours
hardcore the folks that I think are
great whether they're hacking the system
and doing it in 10 hours or 10,000 that
is I think people want to skip that step
yeah I get I get you know for every
email that I get about the craft of
writing yeah I get a thousand about how
to market books and I'm just like hold
on the ratio is all wrong yep that so no
I would agree with that and so that gets
overlooked like I just want to be this
awesome
fashion photographer and hang out with
like awesome you know beautiful people
in crazy locations and it's like dude
you got a beat like actually pick up a
camera and get good that first and then
you might be able to do you know part
how you were able to learn and improve
your freestyle rap skills oh this is a
great question there you're kidding
yourself if you think anyone comes by it
naturally it's a power that you have to
develop over time and when I was in high
school
two-sided to our friends in the high
school were really good at it and I was
the beatboxing kid
College written so much by the time I
got into college and they started doing
it for fun with my friends and just
getting less and less afraid and I can
remember one colored road trip I took it
was I was with three friends we decided
to try I don't recommend this we decided
to drive to Vegas and back in a week but
I got here is this 1:00 a.m. to 5:00
a.m. shift so it's me thriving all we
have are these cans of Red Bull and
everyone else in the car has passed out
and I remember poppy and we lead a bunch
of mixtapes for the ride
we'd worn them all out by the time we
got to about 20 hours in but I just
started drinking Red Bulls and popping
in these hip-hop cassettes and rapping
to myself like I and the Kansas I'm
crazy man this is crazy
and just literally talking to myself
finally survived canvas over the next
person's turn to drive gas station for
gas by the end of it I was a new arrived
and then freestyle Love Supreme of the
other part of that is that I'm in a
hip-hop group where we do show is where
we don't plan what's gonna happen we get
suggested for the audience and we have a
beatboxer we have 2000 keys and we just
make up the show and we just forced
ourselves into that insane situation and
did it until we got good at it and so
I've had my 10,000 by Malcolm Gladwell
Ian zento and now it's sort of now it's
almost like an Instagram filter in my
brain like if I make an acceptance
speech of the communities or the Tonys
like it's easier for me to make it rhyme
than to have just because to play we
love freestyle that I was to talk myself
Apple and I we always used to think big
but we didn't think as big as we made it
our whole thing was how do we stay
traveling when you're in a ghetto or a
province you yearn to travel to see like
you'll one day I want to go to London
one day I want to go to Cambodia see the
ruins
well what's what do I have to do to be
able to travel around my craft now is
writing songs and performing so you
master your craft to do something that
you wanted to do like how do I move my
mom out the projects how do I move my
entire family out the projects my uncles
cousins and a few nieces so you master
your craft to be able to do that the one
thing that I regret to say has been very
common is that nobody wants to see me
work nobody season want to work for it
anymore
you know there's a lot of a lot of
dependency on auto-tune and things that
are nature and I don't get me wrong I
would be a complete hypocrite to sit up
here and say that I haven't used
auto-tune but there's a difference
between using it as a safety net and
using it as wings you know what I mean
you don't jump off the building with the
auto-tune wings and fly around it's not
how you're supposed to do it there is a
thing called singing on key and learning
how to do so and it seems like a lot of
you know a lot of the kids that run up
on me don't even understand what
that is it's like well why why when I
could just auto-tune
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from McLemore on how to master your
craft before that question today I want
to know whose message did you learn more
from in this video Oprah Winfrey or Gary
Vaynerchuk leave it in the comments
below I'm curious to find out thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon and enjoy
the bonus clip
[Applause]
I did the same thing I locked myself out
like all those comics that was it I just
worked my ass off in my room I can't
write can't record and I wasn't great
going into college people that sound
like I'm trying to like learn through
the cracks
by the time I got out college for this
look on
outliers
[Applause]
this book exhibit is very right and that
will fix his plane says it's not about
what the word is not about the talent
this is water with it's about the habits
that she put into that time and he says
it around if you like a master whatever
it is that you love to do if he wanted
that craft attention which you have to
do his work you have to work a lot
our Z says that if you put in around
10,000 hours into that one day
eventually the master that Christ
if you tell yourself a story long enough
you start to believe it don't you
believe it you act like I have Tulsa
what a whale out of handcuffed lightning
though Thunder in jail now you know I'm
bad over the last week I murdered a rock
into the stone hospitalized a brick I'm
so mean I make medicine sick the
fundamental key to success is it can
take between eighteen and two hundred
and fifty four days of taking action for
a new habit to stick I've created a new
course called 2:54 confidence or every
single day for two hundred fifty four
days I will be sending you a video
between 30 seconds and five minutes long
that you start your morning with around
making you feel confident it's
absolutely free check out the link in
the description below to get access